- Look at your cute little jean number.
Okay so you like to dance on camera too.
She's known for dancing,
but I just wanted to show you
you've got competition.
We have a really awesome video
of Nikolaj and his dance moves.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- It is now.
- Be proud.
Be proud of it.
- I just have one question.
How much cake did you eat
of someone else's before
doing this video? (laughing)
- A lot, a lot.
- You were on something.
- I should say that my wife was doing this
dancing show back home,
so I was trying to inspire her that's why.
- You inspired me so well done.
I love it it's awesome.
(audience applauding)
So, your new show is about
you going home to Louisiana, right?
So was that a weird thing?
'Cause it's been a couple years, right?
- Yeah it was two years before
I had went back for the show.
So really long time.
It was like right when I moved out here
I hadn't gone back since, so.
- Yeah.
That's super cool.
So did you get to celebrate
Mardi Gras back home?
Did you...
'Cause now you're 21 right so-
- I know I'm 21.
- You can enjoy Mardi Gras properly.
- No, I haven't been back for Mardi Gras.
My mom is there right now
and she was like sending me pictures
and videos of my brothers,
hanging on the fences and beads.
And there's thongs
and bras everywhere,
the whole thing.
- Just to explain Denmark,
have you ever been to Mardi Gras?
- I was there just after
and I saw beads hanging from every tree.
I did not understand anything.
- Then you missed the show.
(laughing)
Yes, it's quite a show.
- It's crazy.
- It's quite an experience if you ever go.
I've been once.
- Really?
- Yes.
And it's...
Yeah I was like,
"I don't have any beats ma'am,
"but nice job God."
What was your first visit like?
- Oh my gosh.
My first time in Mardi Gras?
- Yeah.
- So crazy.
I remember, like I said,
bras, panties,
people shirtless on floats,
that's the normal thing in Mardi Gras.
So it's really crazy.
There's like...
I mean, now that I'm 21,
I feel like it'd be even more fun,
but really crazy.
And just so spirited I don't know.
Everyone's like family
back home in Louisiana.
So everyone's just all there to have
a good time catch beads,
kind of unsanitary
now I think about it, but yeah.
- The COVID police would frown.
- Right.
The COVID police would hate us.
- Well, let's talk about the new series.
So it's called "Addison Rae Goes Home."
So is that pretty much what happens,
everybody just tracks that journey?
- So I don't go home.
No, I'm kidding.
- Oh God. (indistinct)
- Okay so yeah, I go back to Louisiana,
go back to where I was born
and raised and just get to
reconnect with everybody.
Do a lot of things that I even didn't do
when I lived back home,
which was like craw fishing.
I go craw fishing in the show.
- Oh, all the things that people do-
- Right, kind of like...
You know when people are like,
"Oh you live in Texas,
"do you ride a donkey to school?
"Or a horse?"
- They'd always be like,
"Did you ride a horse to school?"
I'm like, "What?
"Yeah no."
- Me riding an alligator to class, no.
- We took a Honda Accord.
So, I was like, "No."
Yeah.
- Right.
I'm like, "No, we got there safely
"and normally."
But yeah, just kind of doing things
that are basic Louisiana things,
and then doing them with my family,
which is really fun.
- That's awesome.
- Well, what was the hardest
thing to share about yourself?
'Cause you have a few followers.
'Cause it's hard sometimes
for me over 20 years
'cause I'm unfiltered
but there are certain
things that I'm like,
"Ooh maybe I'll keep that for myself."
Has there been anything that you're like,
"Ugh, that was hard to share."?
- Yeah, in the show,
which I hate crying in front of people,
but I do it anyways.
'Cause I'm a big cry baby.
- Me too.
- But I definitely hate it.
Like I feel...
I don't know.
I just hate feeling like...
I feel guilty for some reason when I cry.
Like, Oh, "Oh I don't
want to guilt people."
It feels great.
Don't get me wrong.
- It's a nice release.
- But I feel like it's...
I don't know.
I guess it puts a lot on people
to watch someone cry.
'Cause you're also like,
"What do you do in this situation
"when someone cries?"
But I really opened up just kind of about
my mental health
and like things that,
which I feel like that's so cliche.
'Cause everyone's always like,
"Oh you know..."
It's hard but it's true.
'Cause it's like a really big thing.
And I think maybe not even for me,
but for a lot of people
it's hard to confront those feelings of,
the way you feel about yourself
from a public perception
and seeing, "Oh, maybe I am that way
"that people say that I am.
"And maybe I don't know,
"maybe I do not look great in anything
"and whatever."
You kind of start-
- You can get lost in all
that conversation though.
Especially being young in the industry,
I do feel like people start saying things
and they project on you
and then you get lost.
And you're like, "I'm not that way.
"Am I that way or am I..."
You just start questioning.
- Questioning.
- Yeah.
Does it ever annoy you
when people talk about
you in the public eye
and they have no idea what
they're talking about?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- You're like, "I don't care."
- He's just like, "One, I don't care,
"and two you guys just saw
the dancing video of me.
So what (indistinct).
- I have set the bar.
- Right.